Imagine a puzzle where the pieces fit
themselves together without human help.
These special kinds of puzzles are
actually all around us, on a scale we
normally can't see, and they put
themselves together in a process called
self-assembly. Self-assembly occurs when
molecules spontaneously organize into
complex structures, like smart puzzle
pieces. They are directed to their proper
locations by attractions and repulsions
that result from their electrical
charges, magnetic properties, and
complementary shapes. This means that the
molecules can assemble spontaneously
into ordered rods, sheets, spheres and
other useful structures that are much
bigger than the individual building
blocks. One of these useful structures
self-assembles every time you wash your
hands. Soap is made up of molecules called
fatty acids. These molecules have a
hydrophilic end that's attracted to
water and a hydrophobic chain that's
attracted to oily substances like grease
and dirt. When you wash your hands, the
large hydrophobic chains cluster around
the particles of grease and dirt, leaving
the hydrophilic end sticking out,
surrounded by water. This self-assembled
dirt trap helps the water pilll grease
and dirt off your hands and leaves your
skin squeaky clean!
Remember that self-assembly organizes
materials at a very small scale. In fact,
the molecules involved in self-assembly
are often measured in units of
nanometers or a billionth of a meter--
that's a 1000 times smaller than a
human hair!
This makes self-assembly especially
useful for nanotechnologies, which are
found in everything from computer chips
to electric cars to medical technology.
Speaking of medical technology, one
example is self assembling action is a
new method for getting medicine to the
right places in sick patients, a field
known as drug delivery. Researchers have
found a way to make thin molecular
coatings self-assemble around small
doses of anti-cancer drugs, similar to
how soap molecules surround an oily
substance. These coatings help the
assembly bind selectively to cancer
cells and release most of the drug when
it gets to those cell,s where it can do
the most good.
This also protects healthy cells from
being attacked by the anti-cancer drug.
Remember the hydrophobic tails and
hydrophilic ends of the soap molecule?
Nature uses similar building blocks
called phospholipids in the outer
membrane of each one of your cells. These
building blocks contain one hydrophilic
end attached to two hydrophobic tails.
These pieces self-assemble into a
bilayer, sort of like a nanoscale ice
cream sandwich. The center "ice cream" part
of the bilayer maximizes hydrophobic
interactions between the long tails and
positions of the hydrophilic end "cookies"
in contact with watery environments
inside or outside the cell. The formation
of this phospholipid bilayer keeps
important cellular components like the
nucleus and cytoplasm where they belong,
so that they can do what they're
supposed to do where it's supposed to
happen. This is one of the many
interacting bits and pieces that come
together to make what's arguably the
most beautiful and intricate example of
self-assembly in nature: You